l'eau est ce que tu as une dernière
blague pour ce soir moi sinon tu le nom
alors à temps j'allais l'un est ce que
tu en as une propre
oui c'est un type qui arrive au paradis
et st pierre lui dis bienvenue au
paradis
nom prénom âge profession la maternelle
et je vous arrête tout de suite je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé pour moi je me
souviens de rien tout ce dont je me
souvienne c'est que j'étais menuisier
j'avais un fils et tous et fabien à
l'écouté c'est chiant parce que vous
avez mériter le paradis on le sait moi
j'ai un registre à tenir
vous voulez pas fouiller dans votre
mémoire vous rappelez et non je me
rappelle je t'aime menuisier ça je sais
j'avais un fils saint pierre descout
déchets pas compétent je vais appeler
jésus parce que je peux rien faire pour
vous et je suis arrivé dit quel est le
problème est simple un débat le problème
c'est que monsieur a mérité d'entrer au
paradis mais sauf que je peux pas le
faire rentrer parce que monsieur ne se
souvient de rien et du pardon pardon je
me souviens très bien j'étais menuisier
j'avais un christ jésus regarde le mec
fait papa de ma croyance jésus fait
pinocchio bravo quand même genre maladie
philippe à un type et le 24 décembre au
soir à bethléem
évidemment il dit je vais aller visiter
là ce qui s'est passé il ya deux mille
vingt ans c'est dingue tu tiens donc le
mec va se promène dans votre lait miah
persson tout le monde est en train de
fêter noël et il marche et il s'inspire
il est bien une espèce de petit vent
léger dit quand même c'est fou tout ce
qui s'est passé là et au loin il voit un
type il tire annan et sur l'année une
femme enceinte il faisait bizarre c'est
des attractions mais y'a personne est le
mec vient vers lui tranquillement il
fait beau jour monsieur ils vont jouer a
dit voilà je ma femme va accoucher et on
n'a pas beaucoup d'argent
brossard si vous connaissiez un endroit
pas cher ou mais qui fait une connerie
voyez ici et maintenant ils veulent bien
sûr c'est une connerie et vous appelez
joseph may cry oui comment vous savez et
la femme sur votre femme s'appelle marie
il fait nuit on se connaît hédi ben
voyons et il le fut votre fils qui
venait faisait appeler jésus fut ce
rapport n'est pas portugais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]